hey guys what's up you're watching d LM
model lifestyle I am Daniel Moritz if
you're new to this channel please
subscribe so that you won't miss
anything new and in this video we're
gonna answer one of your questions how
can I be more confident in front of
people and we're starting right now
[Music]
all right so being confident for a lot
of people is not that easy I mean even
for me at some times I'm very very very
nervous depending on the situation and
the people that I'm with right but
certain people are reacted a bit
different when they are nervous like
gets sweaty hands or your your legs
start to shake or some people just keep
quiet they kind of shut down and some
other people they just start talking and
rumbling because they're nervous all
right but why why are we so nervous now
there's a lot of stuff that you can do
about styling and grooming and taking
care of yourself to boost your
confidence but ultimately let's be real
it's about what's going on in your head
right
it's about all these thoughts coming in
about I'm not good enough or I'm ugly or
I cannot speak well enough or you know
all these kind of thoughts it just pops
in from nowhere and when you start to
get these thoughts you know you start to
be nervous and you you just wander and
be like I wish I could be more confident
in front of people well there's a few
things that I learned in international
modeling and I'm gonna share with you
and we're gonna start with some of the
basic stuff and then we're really going
to go into it the first step is to think
before you speak whenever you start to
speak to people and you feel nervous and
you just Rumble off and just bla bla bla
bla bla stop yourself don't do it take a
second calm down
refresh and then go again the worst
thing that you can do is just to speak
whatever pops into your head because you
cannot control it I mean some of you
know once you say something you can
never take it back and it really hurts
people in for example relationships I
mean once you say something that's it my
second point is speak slower and speak
less if you speak slower it gives you
time to really think about what you want
to say you sound more clear and if you
speak slower people can understand you a
lot better and you only need to say a
few things that will get your point
across right if you're already nervous
to speak in front of people then why
would you want to say a lot of stuff and
keep it short to keep it sweet and folk
only on what you want to say right now
right here all right now you probably
heard this quote a lot that says speak
less and listen more and it's so true
people will like you more if you
actually speak less and if you don't
know what to say don't say anything at
all just be quiet just take a step back
just be there and just observe a little
bit refresh
listen to what some other people are
saying and when you are ready to talk
then go
if you feel stupid if you feel silly you
don't know what to do if your hands or
you don't know what to say that's the
perfect time not to do anything and just
to be there all right all right my third
tip is stop stressing or worrying about
what might go wrong right we all want
the outcome to be really good but
sometimes we're so occupied about
worrying and stressing about the outcome
that we cannot focus clearly and what we
want to say right now so there's this
battle going on in your head all right
so what you want to do is you want to
create a habit of pushing out these
thoughts the moment that they enter into
your head you can decide am I gonna go
with this thought or am I gonna push it
up push it out and then you want to
replace them with thoughts of truth what
do you mean with thoughts are the truth
well let me explain thoughts of truth is
very very very strong because once you
believe something to be true you believe
in it and it becomes part of your
thought process and it becomes part of
you all right so then when these lies or
these what-if thoughts come in all right
you can identify them for what they are
and you can push them out and you can
replace them with the thoughts are true
so when you push them out and you
replace them with the thoughts of truth
it pulls up your confidence let me give
you a few examples of thoughts of true
so it's more easier for you to
understand perfection is a sham nobody
is perfect another truth if you are in
new situations or you have to do
something that you've never done
for that's normal so don't be too
stressed or it is normal right it's like
it's like a darkroom you're entering and
you don't know what to expect right
because you don't have the experience
yet if you've experienced something then
you have more confidence of how to
handle it again because you know what to
expect right another example you are you
need there's nobody else there in the
world that is like you
you've been created wonderfully with
certain talents certain gifts and you
don't need to fit in you don't need to
be perfect it's okay to make mistakes
all right step number four get to know
you're strong and your weak points you
have to accept that you will not be good
in everything that you try to do all
right so focus on the stuff that you are
really good at especially when you're
with people all right for example I am
NOT good at telling jokes right so I
don't tell a lot of jokes but I am good
at having a lot of empathy and
understanding people so when I
communicate with people I give them a
lot of love and truth from a heart that
is very genuine
all right tip number five stop worrying
about what other people think about you
now you say okay Daniel it's easy for
you just to say that but it's not easy
to do it well there is a couple of
things that you can do to worry less now
some people say that well yeah they know
there's a few stuff that you can do
drink alcohol or when you talk to people
imagine that they're trees or other
stuff and well it's not a healthy way of
really living so first you need to
understand why you care so much about
what other people think about you now
the truth is you and me have been
brainwashed since we were kids
since I could remember the media out
there on TV radio even if you just drive
somewhere you can see the billboards
it's all these kind of brainwashing
where they show us how to act dress
and behave in certain kind of way so
that we are accepted and liked by people
and so it's become part of who we are
and how we kind of grow up and you have
to let it go and now social media
brought us on a whole bigger scale I
mean people base their value on the
number of likes and the number of
subscribers or followers that they have
so people are getting obsessed with
these questions of am i beautiful enough
do people like me and to live this kind
of way is very dangerous especially if
they're in certain situations they don't
have enough confidence because they feel
that they're not good enough because
they worry too much about what other
people think about them you need to let
it go just let it go now the people who
really like you for who you really are
are the kind of people you really want
in your life if you have people that
don't really care or like you for who
you are then you gotta push them out
negative people are the worst kind of
people to have around you all the time
because they break you down they break
your confidence down and they they break
you down as a person what you need to
understand is what people say or do or
how they act towards you well most of
the time it's got nothing to do with you
but it's got everything to do with them
so let them go so don't make it personal
the less you worry about what other
people think about you the less
complicated life becomes